قد تعتقد أنه ستكون هناك
قيود على هذه المساحة الصغيرة جدًا من
الزخرفة ، ومع ذلك فإننا بطريقة ما نستمر في
تحديث احتمالات أن يكون
الظفر متخصصًا في تجميل الأظافر ، فمن الحميمي
أن تكون وجهاً لوجه ، فأنت تسلم
إليك إشارات  بعضنا البعض
حتى أنك لا تدرك أنك أصبحت
أشخاصًا مقربين جدًا ومستعدون جدًا للتعبير عن
أنفسهم في جيلنا ، نريد أن
نكون
أكثر تألقًا ونريد
التباهي ونريد أن يكون لدينا مثل
الأسماء الملونة الجريئة ويمكننا فعل ذلك من أجل  أولئك الذين
يعتقدون أن المكياج أو الأظافر مجرد
غرور ، ليس بالنسبة لبعض الأشخاص ، إنه تعبيرهم عن
أنفسهم ، إنها
أدواتهم للحفاظ على من يحافظون على
مكانهم في العالم
[موسيقى] ،
اسمي ديفيد إي وأنا
مؤسس الجمال  ضوء جيد للعلامة التجارية
ومؤلف الكتاب ، كان الأولاد الجميلين
عبر تاريخ
البشرية مهووسين بالمسامير ، وأعتقد أن
الأمر يتعلق بشعور الأظافر
أنهم صعبون ، فهم
مختلفون نوعًا ما عن التزلج  إنه مثير ومثير
للجنس
في القرن الثامن عشر في فرنسا ، كان الملك لويس السادس عشر
مهووسًا بأظافره لدرجة أنه
بدأ اتجاه مانيكير باديكير
داخل الأسرة المالكة ، وهناك
العديد من الثقافات العالمية التي قامت بالفعل
بتشبع الأظافر
بعلاجات زخرفية مختلفة كانت
ذات مغزى
.  دليل على وجود
أظافر مذهبة على مومياوات مصرية
وفي الصين تقليد الرجال والنساء النبلاء الذين
يزرعون بضعة أظافر طويلة
جدًا كانت مغطاة بواقيات الأظافر المزخرفة ،
ما يدل عليه حقًا هو
أنك تعرف أن حالة النخبة هذه
الإعفاء من العمل
جيد جدًا لرؤيتك
هذا  هل أظافر سيندي صالون للأظافر
موجه نحو جيل الألفية وجيل زد
وأنا متحمس جدًا لإنجاز أظافري
أول صالونات مانيكير كانت في باريس
في سبعينيات القرن التاسع عشر وكان المشهد
يبدو مألوفًا لنا اليوم
رجال ونساء ينتظرون دورهم
بينما يقرؤون المجلات ،
فإن الأسماء المختارة لهذه الأماكن
، صالون وصالون ، يشير نوعًا ما إلى
اجتماع للجمهور و  مجال
خاص مكان يمكنهم فيه الاسترخاء أيضًا ،
وسأقوم بعمل مسامير لالتقاط الصور في أسبوع الموضة ،
ومجلات الوظائف الإعلانية
التي حاولت أن أصبح أكثر نظافة
وطبيعية في منتجاتي ، ومن
المنطقي بعد ذلك فتح مساحة
تتماشى مع ذلك  كنت تريد أن تشعر وكأنك
مساحة حيث يمكنك أن تأتي مع
أصدقائك وتلتقي بأصدقاء جدد ، ولهذا
السبب تبدو الطاولة مثل طاولة مانيكير طويلة
بحيث يكون الصالون بأكمله في
محادثة عملاقة واحدة تتحدث عن
موضوع اليوم
بصفتك اختصاصي تجميل الأظافر لديك  لكي أكون جيدًا في
قراءة الأشخاص الذين يتناسبون مع
سلوكك ومحادثاتك وسلوكك
معهم ،
أشعر أن الكثير الآن قد ذهب بالفعل
للتجربة وهو نوع من
إخافتي لأنني بحاجة إلى
اللحاق به العطر هو أن رجال أعمالي
يأتون إلى  أقوم بعمل أظافرهم وأعدتها للحصول
على شكل من أشكال الفن يمكن
ارتداؤه
إذا دخل شخص ما ولم
يكن في مكان جيد حقًا ، أشعر
به وأحب أن أسألهم كيف  كان اليوم
فقط جعلهم يشعرون بالراحة
معي لأنه موقف حميم
أن تكون فيه حرفياً تمسك
يد شخص ما لمدة ثلاث ساعات ، يمكن أن
يخبرني الناس بمشاكلهم مثل
خدمتك هي الرعاية الذاتية
الأسلوب الذي  أنا أفعل ذلك جريئًا ومشرقًا للغاية ،
فأنا أحب تجربة الجواهر
والأحجار الكريمة والألماس وأحب
الأشياء المجنونة التي ترسم وكأنها رائعة جدًا ، لكنني
أعتقد أن هناك جمالًا في حقيقة
أنها مؤقتة ،
إنها امتداد لشخصيتك ، فهي
تساعد حقًا في تحول الصحة العقلية
إن عواطفك في شكل من أشكال الفن
هي مجرد علاج علاجي
، ويمكنني أن أفعل ذلك على الناس ، لذا فمن
المدهش
[موسيقى]
مرحبًا ، أنا هانا ،
أنا أحد مؤسسي فتاة
سوداء nelsies فتاة سوداء nelfies هي احتفال
بالنساء السود.  الإبداع ومثل
الطريقة التي نحب بها التعبير عن أنفسنا من
خلال أظافرنا ، تذهب على موقع pinterest كما تذهب إلى
الإنستغرام كما تذهب إلى الإنترنت
لمشاهدة صور عمليات تجميل الأظافر وكانت
دائمًا في أيدٍ تحبها  لم
تكن سوداء ويبدو الأمر وكأن
هناك شيئًا ما بعيد المنال هنا لأنني أعلم أن
هناك نساء سودا
ينجزن أظافرهن كما أعلم أنهن موجودات
لأنني
أطعم أظافر واحدة كونه تطورًا لمصطلح
صورة شخصية الجميع يعرف هذا مثل
هناك طرق معينة عندما
تحاول التقاط أظافرك التي
تشكل يدك ، فهذه بعض الطرق
التي يمكنك من خلالها اللعب بها كما تعلم
للتأكد من إظهار كل شيء
[ضحك]
أعتقد أنه من المهم أن يكون
المانيكير  اشتعلت حقًا في الثلاثينيات
خلال فترة الكساد الكبير في الولايات المتحدة ، فقد اضطرت
النساء حقًا إلى تقليص أي
تساهل شخصي ،
ولكن كان هناك جانب من جوانب
سحر هوليوود التي يمكن أن يصنعاها
مقابل بضعة دولارات فقط وإذا
حدث أي شيء انفجار  ثقافة الأظافر
خلال فترة الركود الاقتصادي في عام 2008 ،
قد يرى بعض الناس أن تقليم
أظافرك ترفًا ، ولكن في
الأوقات العصيبة عندما يكون الناس غير متأكدين
مما يحدث ، فإننا نعتمد على الأشياء التي
نعرفها ونحن  أريد أيضًا أن أشعر بالراحة في
الأشياء الصغيرة ،
فكونك مهووسًا جدًا بتناول
وجبات نظيفة له علاقة
بطفولتي كوني فقيرة ، كنت
نتاج مهاجرين جاءوا من كوريا الجنوبية ،
ربما كان لدينا القليل مما يخصنا
ولكن لا يزال بإمكاننا تقديم أنفسنا
بطريقة نحترم فيها أنفسنا
[الموسيقى]
عندما يتعلق الأمر بعصرنا الحديث
والذكور والرجال أو الأشخاص الذين يقدمون
للجمهور ، ما زلت أعتقد أنه إلى حد كبير
وصمة عار
ولكن إذا عدنا إلى الوراء ، فإننا نفهم أن
الناس دائمًا ما يزينون أظافرهم
وجوههم كوسيلة
للتعبير عن أن الأظافر هي أظافر
وليس لديهم طلاء للهوية الجنسية هو
الطلاء لا يقول أي شيء عن
أنوثتك أو رجولتك بفضل
نجوم البوب ​​مثل bts أو الأرنب السيئ أو ليل ناس x الذين
يعبرون عن أنفسهم ظاهريًا
طرق جديدة ستظهر بها الثقافة ويتطلب
الأمر بعض الأبطال بعض الأشخاص
الجريئين لدفع هذه الفكرة إلى الأمام حقًا